notre invité de ce soir est né à Ouidah
au Bénin et à l'instar des guerrières
Amazon du Dahomey c'est une source
d'inspiration intarissable une icône
mondiale de la musique qui n'a de cesse
de se renouveler autant en genre et en
collaboration et sa musique ne laisse
personne indifférent écouter plutôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue à vous madame Angélique Kidjo
bienvenue dans ce journal de l'Afrique
sur 20 ans 24 vraiment c'est un plaisir
un honneur de vous avoir c'est quoi
d'être aussi de voir ce beau sourire sur
votre visage
alors ce qui nous frappe quand on écoute
on a vu ce petit medley je voulais
vraiment qu'on l'entende pour voir la
variété aussi des styles que vous
abordez et on se dit que on a
l'impression que vous cessez jamais de
vous renouveler en fait que c'est en
permanence pour moi j'ai pas envie de
m'ennuyer on s'ennuie suffisamment dans
la vie sur scène c'est pas possible ah
non non si je m'ennuie là j'arrête
toujours tout de suite de chanter et moi
j'aime bien les défis parce que quand on
est artiste il faut toujours se
questionner il faut toujours se mettre
en danger sinon on se répète et moi je
me répéter ça mais d'où ça vous vient ça
est-ce que ça vous vient de votre mère
qui faisait du théâtre
une famille de 10 enfants qui ont des
caractères différents des opinions
différentes et à la maison nos parents
toujours encourager cette différence
d'opinion toujours encourager le fait
que des gens du monde entier pouvaient
venir à la maison parler des langues
qu'on comprenait pas je me suis jamais
annuelle à la maison donc du coup je ne
vois pas pourquoi je m'amener dans en
faisant la chance en plus la musique m'a
amené à découvrir des endroits où j'ai
jamais mis les pieds à travers les
musiques je connais déjà l'Amérique
avant de mettre les pieds en Amérique à
travers la musique j'ai connu l'Afrique
dans son dans le sens plus large du
terme sans jamais la famille les pieds
en République démocratique du Congo
après j'ai été c'est à dire la musique
pour moi c'est la porte sur le reste du
monde et le monde est multiple beau mais
c'est ah c'est trop bon en tout cas vous
nous influez ça à travers votre musique
et alors votre actualité immédiate c'est
ce concert exceptionnel donc samedi ce
samedi 14 octobre donc à la Philharmonie
il s'agit de rendre hommage à fait la
couture l'autre légende du continent
décédé qui vient évidemment du Nigéria
et alors vous allez reprendre Reman in
light donc de Talking head dont on sait
peu finalement que ils sont déjà
inspirés à la base de félins c'était ça
l'idée au départ mais c'était ça l'idée
en fait quand je suis arrivée en France
à 83 j'ai attendu je suis une cassette
la chanson One signal life time sans
savoir qui c'était et cette chanson m'a
suivi en fait parce que quand on vient
d'une dictature toutes tes musiques là
ne sont pas non pas ils sont pas arrivés
chez vous et c'est comme une retournée à
l'africaine donc rester et un jour j'ai
commencé à me dire il faut que je
reprenne cette chanson et je m'entends
dire par mon mon manager à mon mari mais
c'est le talking moi je connais David
j'ai jamais fait le lien je me dis je
vais écouter tout l'album et j'aime
regarder tu es sûr de ça cet album est
absurde il y a pas de parole les paroles
on comprendrait je dis ah moi j'ai été
élevé par des personnes âgées les
proverbes en Afrique on mange ça tous
les jours mettez-moi la musique et dès
la première chanson je me suis dit je
reprends tout l'album morceau par
morceau mais elle a ramena à l'Afrique
par le la musique de départ qui les
influencé fait l’acouti absolument alors
c'est du coup la boucle est bouclée moi
j'ai dit toujours toutes les musiques
viennent d'Afrique et je le rame je le
ramène toujours toutes les musiques en
Afrique il y a des gens qui sont contre
ça quand je dis ça ils sont pas contents
j'ai dit pour rejeter votre humanité
c'est bon ne me soyez pas d'Afrique
alors soyez vous venez mais tout le
monde est africain parce que nous sommes
des homosapiens et dans notre ADN
l'Afrique est présent tout le temps tous
les jours absolument et alors l'autre
actualité que vous avez parce que avec
vous vous êtes tellement vous êtes
tellement d'énergie il faut vous suivre
pour pouvoir vous suivre alors c'est cet
album avec le trompettiste libanov
français donc Ibrahim Maalouf je propose
qu'on écoute un extrait justement et on
en parle juste après
on n'a pas d'extrait c'est dommage parce
que j'aurais voulu qu'on entende Queen
Saba justement alors par le parlez-nous
de justement de cette collaboration là
mais quand on a décidé de travailler
ensemble le mot but à moi et la question
que je posais à Ibrahim à ce moment là
c'est quel est le lien de l'Afrique et
le Moyen-Orient
moi j'aime toujours l'histoire ramener
l'histoire de l'humanité dans mon
travail et j'ai fait des recherches je
me suis rendu compte que c'est un semis
de la reine Saba est dans la Bible le
Coran la Torah dans toutes les religions
elle est racontée et même on est juste
au Nigéria elle appelait différents noms
je me suis dit ah ça c'est intéressant
j'ai commencé à faire des recherches sur
les énigmes qu'elle posait au roi
Salomon qui était selon le dire le roi
la personne la plus sage du monde ah
j'ai dit ah ça m'intéresse une femme qui
va demander à un homme tu es sage
montre-moi comment tu es sage je vais te
montrer te poser des énigmes et les
énigmes que j'ai choisi sont absolument
intéressantes parce que ça parle
justement des problèmes auxquels nous
faisons face le droit des femmes la
chanson ENI c'est ça
quel est le le
quelle est le truc la chose qui sort qui
n'a pas de plume qui n'a pas de sang
c'est le poussin qui sort de l'oeuvre la
femme au milieu 9 mois 7 jours un enfant
ouais
alors là c'est je pense que les le
public va être
intéressants
moi je donne je donne ces deux-là comme
ça mais il faut pas lire la réponse il
faut écouter la chanson il faut écouter
et se demander ce que ça ça et lire
aussi le texte qui oblige à réfléchir
une une femme qui est au pouvoir en
Afrique noir qui va voir le roi Salomon
pour lui dire si tu es vraiment sage
j'ai besoin de ta Savage ça c'est
sagesse pour gouverner mon peuple on le
fait plus ça aujourd'hui est-ce que nos
dirigeants sont ont de la sagesse c'est
actuel aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on s'écoute
est-ce qu'on a on est-ce qu'on peut
dépasser nos clivage et penser et mettre
au centre de nos préoccupations je dis
je passe surtout des hommes politiques
le bien-être des populations c'est ça la
question aujourd'hui c'est que ça c'est
pas possible en ce moment c'est possible
mais on a on a on a fait beaucoup
d'erreurs en route est-ce que il y aura
un dirigeant qui sera suffisamment sage
et humble pour dire on des erreurs
recommençons à zéro c'est top cet homme
ou cette femme qui dira ça et bien moi
je vais aller je vais aller travailler
avec Direct oui on peut il est pas exclu
d'espérer et alors en attendant c'est ce
qu'on dit absolument et là en attendant
au-delà de la figure de la reine de Saba
il y a aussi le film que porte vailla
Davis donc de womanking où voilà elles
ont réhabilité ces fameuses guerrières
de Dahomey et qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
justement vous vous êtes originaire de
là-bas du Bénin qu'est-ce que ça vous
fait justement que ces figures là
féminines fortes africaines soit pour
une fois j'allais dire en tout cas mise
au devant de la scène comme ça ben il
était temps mais il y a beaucoup
d'histoires qu'on doit raconter en
Afrique beaucoup de d'histoire de femmes
d'hommes
vaillant et valent c'est à dire que
notre histoire nous a été prise parce
que nous ont réduit un esclavage et qui
ont nous ont colonisé
et nous sommes toujours dans cette
attitude d'attendre que les autres
parlent à notre nom moi
non je raconte ma propre histoire ne
parle pas pour moi nous avons des têtes
de chez nous nous avons des historiens
chez nous nous avons des gens
fantastiques en Afrique il serait temps
qu'on commence à prendre à nos enfants
nos propres histoires avant de leur
apprendre l'histoire des États-Unis du
reste du monde nous d'abord on doit
comprendre notre histoire et à la
connaître pour que quand l'esclavage
commence recommencera parce que
l'histoire est un éternelle
recommencement qu'on sache ce qui se
présente et qu'on se battent contre
l'esclavage et contre la colonisation
parce que les gens jouent aujourd'hui
les gens sont en colère les jeunes sont
en collants en Afrique mais ils ont pas
suffisamment d'éducation ne pas
suffisamment des formations pour être
fort et être fier de leur propre
histoire et dire mais non moi je ne suis
pas réduit à ma pauvreté je suis
quelqu'un qui vient d'une culture riche
il faut qu'on soit on le raconte ses
histoires là il est absolument
indispensable que les cinéastes les
comptes les écrivent tous autant que
nous sommes nous nous mettons servis de
nos histoires et qu'on les raconte
absolument c'est très important et
l'autre Pange puis dire si je devais en
choisir qu'un dans votre carrière et
dans votre dévouement c'est aussi votre
engagement auprès des de la jeunesse et
en particulier c'est dans la droite
ligne de ce qu'on disait des jeunes
filles vous êtes ambassadrice pour
l'UNICEF vous avez votre fondation donc
c'est très important pour vous cet
engagement et on sait qu'il vous tient à
cœur mais ça me tient à cœur parce que
je me rends compte au jour d'aujourd'hui
ça fait longtemps que je m'en suis rendu
compte mais plus que jamais maintenant
surtout après la pandémie si les femmes
sont centre de tout partout pas
seulement en Afrique en particulier les
femmes africaines sont la colonne sont
les colonnes vertébrale de l'Afrique
sans les femmes l'Afrique s'écroule et
on passe notre temps à écouter les
hommes qui nous parlent des femmes et
qui veulent réduire la femme atteindre à
un objet un objet de désir un objet à
une serviette à une serpillière mais
rien Pâques à un être humain les hommes
africains les hommes en général n'a
jamais s'il y a pas de femme il y a pas
d'homme sans femme ce n'est pas un homme
qui donne naissance à un homme et à une
femme il faut deux personnes donc
l'homme est forcé d'être le partenaire
de la femme et la femme est aussi force
d'être partenaire de l'homme un homme ne
peut pas se dire fier de cette petite
fille de sa mère de ses sœurs de sa
tante de ses femmes s'il n'a pas le
respect pour la femme le reste pour la
femme on doit l'inculquer à nos ans à
nos enfants nous les femmes africaines
nous devons élever nos petits garçons en
leur faisant dire en leur savoir leur
petite sœur n'est pas le bobonne le
petit soit d’être respecté leur petite
sœur aussi une voix à la maison laissée
parler les petites filles à la maison et
les petits garçons et arrêtons de dire
que les enfants n'ont pas de voix
absolument ce message personnel je le
prends pour moi aussi merci infiniment
Angélique Kidjo d'être venu et c'est
ainsi que nous referme ce journal de
l'Afrique merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
suivi et en particulier tient de wida à
Paris en passant par Los Angeles partout
où vous soyez restez avec nous faire
l'actualité continue sur France 24
[Musique]